James the Curtis said John roca for
Collider yeah we love it was the first
one I was shown oh that's clear and you
guys have been amazing amazing you guys
were in Toronto also yes every member of
Steve Weintraub highly Haley pouch all
big fans of the horror genre all massive
fans of you coming back to Halloween but
I remember seeing the original I'm of an
older age than them and saw the original
and I was incredibly excited to have you
come back to it and you really kicked
some ass what was that experience like
for you finally stepping back in and
getting to kick some ass on your own
well I mean it's funny the ass-kicking
part is the fan favorite part but from
my standpoint I didn't go into it too
because I got to kick Michaels bottom I
went I was particularly drawn because it
was a movie about trauma and about what
happens you know we we have horror
movies that are horrific and we have
these horrific events that take place
but we leave the movie theater and then
we complain that the dishwasher doesn't
work you know the trauma that occurs for
these characters for 40 years I felt was
very important that David understood
that and was and was really giving
Laurie great honor to acknowledge that
her experience of her life was very
challenged and then kick his ass you
know what I mean and then you realize
that in fact it was all like a spider's
web
yeah but in order to go to the spider's
web you also had to see the very fragile
person and I was grateful that that was
the angle I think if from the opening
set and I was kicking
but I think it wouldn't have had the
emotional response that I think people
actually had it's a fantastic answer
because it's absolutely true in order to
do one thing you have to lay the
groundwork for the other you've got two
going on that was the original Halloween
you know the original Halloween you
cared about Laurie
right her poor little repressed
virginity and her sort of you know when
Annie says poor Laurie scared another
one away if it was you understood this
was this repressed young girl who wanted
love and maybe why Michael saw her as
the perfect victim for himself I'm not
surprised her sing the song I wish I had
you all alone just the two of us I would
hold you close to me so close you know
she's a she was longing yeah for love
and I like that that was how we
approached it right well you shooting
these two are you shooting them right
now back to back what's the plan there
same tone one right now with Kyle coming
back as Lindsay and Anthony Michael Hall
has come back to sort of step into Tommy
Wallace's shoes and then what I love is
what David and Danny and company did is
they took they made the original they
connected the dots for 40 years
yes now they're going back to really
unpack the first movie bringing back all
those characters whose lives were
affected right by what happened in 1978
and then the last movie is the sort of
cultural phenomenon of violence that's
what the movie the third movie
ultimately is a very powerful
[Music]
examination of violence and it's gonna
be down and dirty and gritty kind of for
the low for the same kind of budget they
got to spend a little bit more oh no no
no no oh no yeah but it's a different it
comes at it from a slightly different
way yeah you'll like it
I think ralick promise if you trust me
on any level if I ever let you down
well I did in Halloween
whatever that it's true I swear I had to
like h2o plus one whatever the next one
was no virus I let you down I'm so sorry
no you never let us down with your
performance if you believe in me at all
I promise you what David Gordon Green
has come up with as a way to complete
this trilogy is sensational all right
we're all excited for it a Collider you
guys have been amazing
let the Moana really really supportive